the Mortal Kombat games have been the
subject of too many rumors and fan
theories to count some of the crazy
stuff like unlocking reptile proved to
be true and now we've unearthed even
more secrets you'll need to use a good
old fashioned arcade cabinet to do this
but you'll be able to access some secret
menus when you do website the cutting
room floor on earth the hidden menus
last year but thanks to youtube user
your mkay arcade source we got to see
them in action well action might not be
the right word since the hidden menus
contain diagnostic tests coin-op
information and character endings but
hey the secret is a secret and who knows
what else is hiding inside those
machines it's been nearly 24 years since
Mortal Kombat first appeared in arcades
so the fact that we're still discovering
this stuff is impressive the latest
entry in the series mortal kombat x i'll
hit store shelves on march first and hey
maybe there's some more stuff to find in
there too if we find anything crazy
you'll see it on gamespot
you